reddit has become an absolute global
phenomenon take us back to when reddit
was founded what when did you guys found
it and why where were you
so Steve Huffman and I started it
technically we started the company while
we were in Charlottesville Virginia as
undergrads at UVA mr. mr. Jefferson's
University I see some Wahoo's in there
the the the original company we had
started was called my mobile menu or
mmm-hmm
losing them because it was a great name
or a terrible I'm I'm really proud of my
branding but all right fine my mobile
menu menu and that's what my mobile menu
did I'm sensing you would have not
invested in us we we wanted to allow
people to order food from their cell
phones five blocks away from the
Starbucks thousand five two thousand
five so the smartest planet was Rio
exactly what stylists are some jank I we
were drivin s saluting general yeah so
yeah check it was it was a little early
but we knew we were gonna do it we knew
we were we were gonna do it I talked
Steve out of taking a nice comfortable
job at a software company in Virginia
and and then we heard a guy named Paul
Graham give a talk in Harvard called how
to start a startup and it was during our
senior year spring break we were the
only people in Virginia going to Boston
on our senior spring break because
beaches sucked for laptops the the glare
there's no internet why would you go to
why'd you go to a beach yeah why would
you go to a beach during spring break
and absurd hang out on the beach with a
bunch of girls I would you had a very
different college experience exactly I
did so anyway we at level 60 and World
of Warcraft which is true that's true so
you have the chance to go party in Miami
you decide get we're going to Boston
here Paul Graham talk about startup yeah
fantastic and it's just before before YC
before white sands my to say this was
just Paul Graham the sort of Internet
pundit who had had success in the first
boom making the first online store yahoo
stores or via web which was originally
called and Steve was just a huge fan of
his because Steve was a Lisp programmer
and he Lisp programmers of course not
where there's one yeah I'm sorry oh well
Steve you see the homeless guy across
the street all this programmer whispers
i vb we're going yeah but we we we went
up there because you know steve is a
huge fan of his essays and i thought you
know what this seems like it'll be
really useful it's called how to start a
startup and we met with him afterward
Steve got a book signed and then I
followed and I was like touch her Graham
it would be really worth buying the cost
to buy it would really be worth buying
you a drink
to pitch you on our idea we came away
from Virginia and he was just shocked I
think we came all the way from Virginia
yeah I said alright we'll meet up and
and we met with them and pitched him hmm
for like an hour and he loved him and
and sure enough three weeks later he
announces Y Combinator and we applied
and we went up there interviewed did a
great job interviewing and they rejected
us and yeah and then we got drunk and
the next morning sowait telling us to
that moment where you got rejected
because this is the first year there
wasn't really a formal process no no no
one knew so well like wow we got a phone
call that night and and I remember this
this this is I finally admitted this in
the book I hadn't actually told anyone
it's just easier to type that night Paul
calls and he says really sorry you're
just it's just not gonna work and I
don't know what it wasn't that abrupt he
was polite about it but anyway we got
really drunk and we hung out with a
bunch of friends of ours who were
Harvard graduates and we met some of
their friends who had just gotten jobs
great banking jobs at like I know Lehman
Brothers probably and and they were
bragging Bear Stearns they were so proud
so cocksure and and they were bragging
about all the money they were gonna make
and and I I was so ashamed I was like
yeah you think that's cool we just got
into Y Combinator it's this seed stage
accelerator for tech startups and we're
gonna just do amazing stuff with mmm and
and it sucked so much as the lie was
coming out of my mouth it felt so bad
and so I drank more and always a good
solution it's yeah well there might be
well yeah yeah it was for that night
okay wait so now how does our hero or
heroes get accepted back into Y
Combinator blackmail no we called we we
took the train back to Virginia that
next morning hours and and Paul calls
and I pick up and he says listen we like
you guys we just don't like the idea
it's too early for mobile if you if
you're willing to kill this company a
year in that you've been working on will
let you into the program and it took us
about five seconds
and we got on the next train back to
Boston sat with Paul for about an hour
and he just sat us down and said all
right forget mobile build something on
the web what problems do you guys have
every single day and Steve was a heavy
slash dot user I read a bunch of tabs
every morning of news websites but
neither one of us had a solution for
really news like a new kind of web site
that would be a front page for
everything and and Paulie mentioned
delicious slash popular now note at this
point I have not said the word Digg
because we did not know about dig but we
knew about delicious slash popular I
mean and in in fairness that was Kevin's
inspiration for Digg he always gave
credit to delicious which was started
here in New York by Josh Josh Magette
Joshua chapter
delicious calm which was a bookmarking
tool allowed people just said these were
the things that were bookmarked the most
today yes in bookmarks with a signal yes
and and we noticed so we had never used
the papaw was it was talking about it
and we thought you know what there's an
interesting thing here the byproduct of
people bookmarking reference material
you know to look at later like Ajax
tutorials or like travel planning was an
interesting kind of zeitgeist but it was
only a zeitgeist for reference material
not for what was new so like here's
social bookmarking it's doing its thing
really well until Yahoo acquires it and
kills it and we needed to be something
else that was a place for people to go
to find the more ephemeral news of the
day and that's how we got started with
reddit now it took a while for it to
catch on but it's become quite a
phenomenon when did you know that this
was more than just you know a small
little boutique startup effort we knew
we were on to something when the great
Jason Calacanis was trying to buy our
users
yes that and you're being facetious well
it was it was interesting because at
that moment we realized it was certainly
make is more clear
Y Combinator was nothing no one had ever
heard of it it wasn't anything that was
import
to anyone was based in Boston the reason
when 10 people in the class the first
one they're American companies the demo
day which is today the most contested
I'd argue in the world had like 12 of
Paul's rich friends who were just like
what the [ __ ] we doing here you said
there was gonna be free food and booze
and who is this kid talking on stage
about reddit's you know and and we were
in we were in Somerville Massachusetts
we you know literally never got on we
never got pressed in TechCrunch until
the day we got acquired we were we felt
very much on our own in this on in our
own little world and we were tooted in a
little apartment working in our
underwear in between games of World of
Warcraft on something and it took months
for anyone to really start caring but
when we saw signals like that we thought
you know what we're on to something
and and thankfully we had great mentors
in Paul because when we found out about
dig about two weeks after we launched
and I looked like a fool for doing a
really terrible competitive analysis he
said he said some great advice and I
found the email because I was tired of
people always asking me there's your
copy dig we found the email it we just
said meet the enemy dig calm and Paul
was like you idiot don't be worried
competition competitors will never beat
you you only beat yourself and rather
prophetic yeah